today we're talking about optimizing
with recommenders Google cloud
certifications and datacenter security
I'm priyanka regalia and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news from the safety of
home with recommenders our goal is to
suggest quick easy ways to optimize your
cloud for price performance and security
several recommenders are already
available today including virtual
machine recommender spiral insights and
iam recommender and now we're releasing
the beta of our new recommendations hub
which highlights proactive
recommendations in one place for you to
view and act on two years ago we created
a gaming solution to bring real world
games to life with the Google Maps
platform one traditional release was
with a limited group of game studios we
plan to expand to independent game
studios and developers so we focused on
building a scalable infrastructure that
would support all developers and now
we're releasing our Google Maps platform
gaming solution to all mobile game
developers to create engaging immersive
real world games check out the blog to
learn more and try it for yourself our
Google cloud training allows you to
build cloud skills while our
certifications help organizations buy an
export cloud talent we are continually
working to improve our learning pads and
now we are announcing three new
initiatives we are introducing Google
cloud skill badges so you can show off
your demonstrated skills and expertise
we are offering six-week programs to
help experienced cloud professionals
prepare for the certification exams
and since our exam centers are currently
closed we have created online proctored
testing for three of the certification
exams at Google cloud we tend to obsess
about data security and we offer plenty
of products and services to help our
customers secure that data but we're
just as focused when it comes to
physical security of our data centers
after a series of checks and approvals
my teammate Stephanie Wong was given
permission to visit an actual data
center and create a video showcasing how
safe
secure your data really is in this video
Stephanie will show off the six security
layers from the secure perimeter to the
data center floor that fewer than 1% of
Googlers ever see it's a pretty cool
behind-the-scenes look so be sure to
check it out
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you